comment faire de la france un leader en
matière d'intelligence artificielle en
jouant sur nos avantages qu'ils
correspondent d'ailleurs à la dynamique
de l'intelligence artificielle
1 nous avons les talents regardez qui
dirige l'intelligence artificielle dans
tous les grands groupes dans le monde
sont des français et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont d'ailleurs ils sont en train
de continuer à ouvrir des centres de
recherche d'innovation en france
donc nos talents l'école de maths les
écoles d'ingénierie d'intelligence
artificielle de datacert hisse donc on
va continuer à former double et même
dans le quinquennat le nombre
d'étudiants dans le supérieur et toutes
les formations les à l'intelligence
artificielle ensuite développé beaucoup
plus fortement encore nos réseaux de
recherche recherche fondamentale et
recherche applicative on l'a vu ici très
bien à l'institut curie avec cette start
up aux kings mais c'est permettre nous
d'investir sur la recherche fondamentale
mais de le faire avec justement des
partenariats ouverts d'avoir un réseau
de paris à toulouse en passant par les
différentes centre d'excellence français
avec l'inria comme acteur qui
consolidera tout ça et des partenariats
avec le secteur privé et un
investissement massif on va mettre un
peu plus d'un milliard et demi sur
l'intelligence artificielle au cours du
quinquennat avec différents appels à
projets ensuite c'est d'avoir donc des
chaires d'excellence d'attirer les
meilleurs talents internationaux publics
et privés et d'avoir cet effet de masse
et d'accélérations puis enfin c'est la
donnée parce que si on veut que les
choses avancent beaucoup plus vite faut
ouvrir les données et donc pour cela
nous avons une chance c'est que la
france est un pays on reproche souvent
jacobins centralisée donc on a beaucoup
de données qui sont souvent maîtrisé par
des acteurs publics c'est le cas de la
santé l'assurance maladie française
c'est un retour aux sources de données
incomparable n'y a pas d'équivalent au
monde et donc on va l'ouvrir on a mis en
place donc un centre national de gestion
des données personnelles qui va
permettre de protéger à la fois votre
anonymat de respecter nos règles et nos
préférences on veut pas que votre
information ski à savoir sur vous
circulent mais en un même lit misant et
en suivant aussi l'utilisation qui est
faite des données qu'on ouvre c'est à
dire on veut que et une retombée pour
nous on veut être sûr que ça correspond
à nos règles de déontologie permettre à
des acteurs justement de l'intelligence
artificielle d'innover
et donc on va mettre en place des
protocoles d'ouverture des données santé
et utiliser beaucoup mieux
les données en france on va avoir comme
ça une série de protocoles expérimentaux
je vais les annoncer dès cet après-midi
sur la mobilité et véhicule autonome sur
la santé et on va faire un appel à
projets à toutes les expérimentations
sur ce point là donc voilà talent
recherche financement données c'est la
clé pour faire de la france un leader de
l'intelligence artificielle
sachant que nous sommes aujourd'hui
d'ores et déjà en europe l'un des
premiers pays et nous avons tout pour
réussir et comment éviter la fuite des
cerveaux simplement rendant la france
attractive savez les cerveaux niçois y
vont pour l'argent ce n'est pas
forcément vrai toujours
donc il faut ces chaires d'excellence
qui permettent d'abord bien rémunérés
dans nos universités nos sites de
recherche
ce qu'on va continuer à développer en
partenariat faut attirer les meilleurs
industrielle on à facebook google
samsung a annoncé on a dit mind on a des
start up et des grands groupes
internationaux qui met ici leur centre
et donc il recrute aussi des talents en
france et trois en ayant une recherche
publique privée extrêmement innovante
qui va attirer les talents les talents
attire les talents c'est un effet comme
ça d'accumulation quelqu'un qui est un
génie dans les data science dans les
maths dans les probabilités autant de
secteurs qui s'agrège autour de
l'intelligence artificielle
ce qu'il veut surtout c'est travailler
dans les meilleures conditions avec les
gens qui sont très forts dans ces
disciplines
on doit faire de paris saclay toulouse
l'ensemble de nos centres de recherche
strasbourg / par exemple quand on parle
de médecine et tous les autres ce grand
centre français des centres d'excellence
où les talents reste et surtout viennent